[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So we are going to start a new
chapter in this class, Feynman
Calculus.
The purpose of this
very first introduction
is to just set the stage.
And we do this by
recapping what we've
discussed so far in the first
three weeks of this course.
So first we
introduced the player
in the field-- the elementary
particles, the matter
particles, and the
force carriers.
We have seen that there are
three generation of fermions,
that there's leptons and quarks.
We have seen that
they, eh, in principle,
interact in different ways
with those force carriers.
We have seen that there
are three kinds of charges,
or three kinds of interactions--
the electromagnetic interaction,
the weak interaction,
and the strong interaction.
Then we moved on and had
a quantitative discussion
of relativistic kinematics.
So there's quite a set of
useful problems we can look at.
For example, we are
wondering, how much energy
does my proton need in a
beam on a fixed target where
we want to produce antiprotons?
So those problems we were able
to discuss and quantitatively
figure out what the answers
to those questions are.
Then we looked at
Feynman diagram.
We are able to read
them and understand
what they principally mean.
And then we had a discussion
last week on symmetries.
And we introduced parity, we
introduced charge conjugation,
we looked at CP
and CP violation.
We had a qualitative discussion
on decays and scattering.
We defined what a
geometrical cross-section is.
And now we are really starting
the quantitative discussion
of particle dynamics.
We do this now in the
next video by introducing
Fermi's golden rule.
And then we study
a toy theory which
is simplified such that
the algebra involved is not
going to be too
much of a hassle,
so we can focus on understanding
the following Feynman
rules in order to
calculate decay rates
and scattering cross-sections.